this season on the boys
[Music]
i don't want a murderer in the same
house with my kid
[Music]
season three has come to an end and i'm
crying harder than homelander being told
he's a disappointment in this video
we'll be going over that final episode
and insane theories for season 4 which
was recently greenlit there's also a
boys spin-off show called varsity which
has just started production which stars
arnold schwarzenegger's son patrick as a
superhero called golden boy so make sure
you're subscribed i'll be covering that
show too now pour yourself a delicious
milk and coke we've got a lot to cover
it's been a few episodes since we've
seen a becca and homelander's son ryan
who had to change locations of his
protective custody after homelanders
hostile take over a vaude but as we saw
last episode victoria newman gave
homelander his son's location as the two
of them continue their tumultuous yet
mutually beneficial relationship
victoria is willing to do whatever it
takes to get what she wants heck she
betrayed her adoptive father stan edgar
and now is involved in an act of treason
to solidify her place as vp currently
victorian homelander need robert singer
to win the presidency apparently his
poll numbers are high and he'll likely
win the presidency after that all bets
are off this is likely all a ploy to
have robert singer win then they kill
him off and have victoria become the
president a soup president who also has
a soup daughter we never really found
out what happened to her after her
mother injected her with compound v
it'll be interesting to see if season 4
follows victoria on the campaign trail
or if they'll just start the season with
robert singer already as president ryan
throws a baseball really really far a
stark contrast to how bad he was at it
in season two it's also a visual
confirmation that his powers are growing
the scene is also a throwback to 2006's
superman returns remember the one with
he who must not be named in which
superman also throws a baseball
extremely far i also love how ryan is
wearing red white and blue homelanders
colors speaking of which look who it is
homelanders come to repair the
relationship with his son telling him
he's not mad for what he did meaning
accidentally kill his own mother at the
end of season 2. if there's anyone who
knows about accidents it's him
now grace tries to call for help but
homelander can sense that he just wants
to tell his son that he loves him no
matter what he does and the two hug
outside vaught tower we have two
distinct groups facing off against one
another after the live stream starlight
secretly took of homelanders sparked
outrage there's the pro-homelander
faction known as the home teamers and
pro-starlight faction called
starlighters each group is a satire on
the current left and right divide in
american politics on the right we have
the nationalist pro-gun fascists one
dude even has a swastika and on the left
we have the woke snowflake liberals if
you thought the politics were bad just
wait till next season with the attorney
general on the way ashley has to get rid
of maeve who's locked up in vaught tower
i love this zebra dress she wears which
reflects her character merely prey in a
world of lines that could kill her at
any moment now ashley does show a little
compassion towards maeve here saying
that she's sorry we know from a few
episodes ago that ashley has basically
gone along with homelander because she's
scared but that still doesn't excuse
some of the terrible things she's done i
love this cool detail of maeve's uneaten
food in the corner as she gets knocked
out by gas almost as if she were on a
hunger strike or concerned her food
could be poisoned huey's a bit concerned
at this black blood coming from his nose
a side effect of the compound v which we
found last episode can kill you in about
three to five doses something butcher
fails to mention to him huey looks over
some pizza rolls a throwback to season
one where huey talked about hating them
how much i
hate pizza rolls we'll later find out
this was because it reminded him of his
sad weak father who would make them to
eat away his feelings about his wife
leaving him huey hasn't seen his mom in
years and that's another big character
that i could see being introduced next
season butcher's still going with the
plan to grab some more temp v kill black
noir then finish up with homelander and
even though soldier boy just found out
homelander is his son it's left up in
the air what he's going to do here will
he go through the deal he's made with
huey and butcher or will he join his son
to make an unstoppable team while being
transported maeve is able to escape that
cannot be good news for ashley
frenchie's been able to acquire one of
the only doses of the nerve agent
novacek which they found out last
episode can knock soldier boy out he's
had to pay three bugattis worth of
starlight's money to acquire it and
considering a new bugatti can range from
about 2 to 12 million dollars that's a
hell of a lot of money and mad props to
frenchie for storing it in a starlight
wish perfume bottle frenchie gives a pep
talk to mother's milk who is beating
himself up over beating up todd in front
of his daughter no less but frenchie
tells him we're all a little bit broken
and that janine should see the man he
truly is calling mm the best man he's
ever known frenchie also says this quote
of all men's miseries the bitterest is
this to know so much and to have control
over nothing it's a quote from 5th
century bc historian herodotus and
really encapsulates mm a man who knows a
lot like homelander is bad but can't do
anything about it frenchie tells him to
get back on his lexapro something we saw
him taking a few episodes ago for his
depression and anxiety maybe this will
help him with his chronic tapping
something his daughter notices later on
in the episode also shout out to
frenchie for having seen 27 dresses
after hollander was caught on camera by
starlight vaut stock has plummeted and
poor ashley has to tell him they moved
maeve without his permission just wait
till he finds out she escaped but this
scene is really about black noir's
return to vaught he ran away after
finding out soldier boy had returned but
now armed with the power of buster
beaver he's ready to team up with
homelander to take soldier boy down and
i love how he spelled soldier here
hinting that when soldier boys bashed
part of his brains out in nicaragua it
affected almost all of his cognitive
functions not just his speech at this
vaught gas station where he can purchase
some smooth a-train cigarettes butcher
knocks hughie out throughout the season
we've seen how butcher has equated huey
to his younger brother lenny but unlike
lenny he isn't going to let huey kill
himself by knocking huey out he is
preventing him from taking more temp v
and thus saving his life bonus points if
you caught the queen maeve snacks a
train's brother is settling into his new
life unable to use his legs a result of
bluehawk's attack at the community
center i also like how they even added a
stair lift outside his home a train has
started his recovery after his heart was
replaced with blue hawks can i get a
what what now he only needs a cane and
he tells his brother he'll soon get
everything back including his races and
endorsements but at what cost he killed
bluehawk even though he was doing this
for his brother it's not what his
brother wanted this was not justice for
nathan it was revenge he wanted his kids
to see blue hawks mugshot on the tv
instead of his brother murder him nathan
says don't say you did that for me
you've only ever been about yourself
which echoes what ashley said a few
episodes ago you did not give a [ __ ]
about all the collateral you caused then
now all of a sudden you care
because it happened to you nathan never
wants to see his brother again starlight
picks up huey the last time they saw
each other they didn't leave on good
terms
hughie teleported her against her will
from herogasm in an attempt to save her
from soldier boy he apologizes to her
telling a story about how he thought his
father was weak but realizing sometimes
strength comes simply by being there for
those you love well i guess we found
quentin tarantino's favorite episode of
the season maeve has found refuge at
mother's milk says huey and starlight
arrive frenchie has drowned himself in
drugs which kimiko doesn't take too
kindly to ever since the altercation
with little nina he's needed something
to cope with the pain that maybe she was
right the only thing that changes in his
life is who holds the chain around his
neck and just like french she gave
kimiko a pep talk a few episodes ago
kimiko returns the favor telling him the
past is not who we are this talk seems
to work as we'll later see frenchie
sticking up for himself in front of
butcher she calls him monkua which means
my heart huey tells maeve that soldier
boy is homelander's father while
starlight tries contacting vaughn to get
them to evacuate the tower the team
seems hell-bent on taking down
homelander and soldier boy and hughie
makes an impassioned plea that they save
butcher we save everyone
even if they don't deserve it at the
boys hq butcher goes over the vaught
tower schematics he also ignores calls
from grace mallory who undoubtedly would
be warning him that homelander took his
son but it's soldier boy's story about
his childhood that gives us the biggest
insight into why he'll eventually turn
his back on his son and decide not to
side with him his father was a rich
steel mill owner and no matter what he
did soldier boy was nothing but a
disappointment to his father even when
he enrolled in the compound v
experiments and became the world's
strongest man his father told him a real
man wouldn't have taken a shortcut no
matter what he did he'd never be able to
earn his father's love he'd be nothing
but a disappointment and the irony of
the situation is that soldier boy
becomes just like his father later
telling homelander that he is weak and
nothing but a disappointment also for
all you horndogs out there this is jane
wyman the actress soldier boy made sweet
passionate love to at the co-check she'd
go on to marry ronald reagan soulja boy
tells butcher that he always wanted kids
and actually believes he might have a
few running around somewhere out there
but i don't think the writers would
bring in a homeland or brother at least
till about season 7. unlikely but i'll
throw it out there anyway we never
really saw any fallout from maeve and
butcher's one night stand with maeve
leaving at the end of the season i doubt
we'll see any butcher babies noir
sharpens his blades something pretty
meaningless since they wouldn't be able
to penetrate soldier boy's skin
homelander tells him that soldier boy is
his father but noir already knew this
for homelander this is a betrayal after
all homelander told noir he was the only
person he could trust
seriously you're the only one i can
count on and he's kept this secret from
him all these years this betrayal ends
in homelander killing noir or at least
that's what it seems like as we see
buster beaver fade away from his helmet
love the addition of the robert singer
billboard in the back here later in the
episode they'll even add a remembering
maeve one butcher looks over a vial of
temp v knowing it will likely kill him
as they're interrupted by huey maeve
starlight mm frenchie and kimiko looking
for soldier boy they want to stop him
before he goes into vaught tower and
blows the place up something that could
result in hundreds dying but it's maeve
here that does something unexpected she
chucks the nova chalk and breaks mm's
gun ultimately siding with butcher
homelander has to die even if it means
some residual casualties at vaught i
really thought that deep down you were a
hero
well you were wrong maeve will actually
end up sacrificing herself becoming a
hero at the end of the episode starlight
huey kimiko frenchie and mm are locked
in the safe and i love this spot the
villain propaganda poster here where the
boys have pointed arrows at homelander
butcher shuts off the power reminding us
that starlight gets her power from
nearby light sources something that
we'll see play out later in the episode
eight train ashley and the deep listened
to the audio recording of starlight
pleading that the tower be evacuated
recording the deep got from the crime
lab which he's now calling angelfish
homelander shows them he's killed noir
essentially telling them that this is
what happens to those who keep secrets
he thought that one day his team at
vaught would become his family but now
he's stuck with these guys disappointed
in them the deep being the bootlicker he
is asks if there's anything he can do
homelander will whisper something in his
ear which the deep thinks is treason
this is homelander asking he kills
senator lamar bishop paving the way for
victoria newman to take over his role as
robert singer's vp we also learn why
ashley still has this great set of hair
after watching her lose it for three
straight seasons it's a wig homelander
also digs into a train asking him how he
could quote kill one of their own this
is the second time in the season where
homelander has brought up this idea of
supes being different than humans vicky
i'm glad you chose your own kind with
victoria newman potentially one step
away from the presidency i wonder if
homelander is setting up for the
eventual takeover of humanity by supes
kimiko and starlight easily break out of
the vault and they devise a plan to
break into vaught tower frenchie will
use the lab there to concoct his own
version of the neurotoxin that can bring
down soldier boy remember he's a chemist
and we saw him macgyver things together
at the sage grove center in season 2. as
they leave huey eyes a leftover vial of
temp v he'll later have to decide if
he'll take it to save starlight's life
more on that in a bit as homelander
watches archive footage of his father
liberating a concentration camp one
which was probably staged or that
soldier boy just showed up after it was
already liberated he's interrupted by
maeve butcher and soldier boy himself i
love how there's these posters for
vaughten friends a play on fox and
friends as well as the stephanie jackage
report a play on special report with
bret baer or simply fox report with jon
scott homelander says that butcher has
gone scorched earth a callback to their
meeting in episode 1 where both sides
would do whatever it takes to bring the
other down but the episode has been
building up to this point on whether or
not soldier boy will side with his son
or side with butcher and homelander
makes things even more difficult by
bringing out ryan telling soldier boy
that this is his grandson and that they
can finally be a family but soldier boy
ends up calling his son weak and a
disappointment leading to a battle with
ryan caught in the middle maeve butcher
and soldier boy hold homelander as
soldier boy charges his power that would
ultimately make homelander powerless but
just as homelanders about to be
destroyed ryan laser eyes soldier boy
and soldier boy is like
soulja boy gets the upper hand ready to
kill both homelander and ryan in one go
this is where butcher has to make a
decision does he let soldier boy go
through with this or does he stop him
saving ryan but also letting homelander
live so later tell soldier boy he made a
promise to becca in season two
you promised me you keep him safe maeve
takes on homelander while soldier boy
finishes off butcher but is saved in the
nick of time by starlight and mm in the
lab kimiko protects frenchie as he puts
together the necessary ingredients to
create the nerve gas she listens to
maniac from the footloose soundtrack the
movie that was playing in the background
when starlight patched kimiko up ashley
tells her assistant also ashley
seriously that's her name in the credits
that the helicopter is reserved for svps
and hire man i love this character so
much but she's such a [ __ ] maeve
actually makes homelander bleed here but
in the process gets her eye gouged we'll
later see her bandaged up and it looks
like she'll never have use of that eye
again although he gets shot in the leg
frenchie finishes the nerve agent which
he gives to kimiko she'll get tossed
aside like a ragdoll dropping the
canister on the ground while butcher
fights soldier boy he actually manages
to crack his shield which i thought was
pretty badass but soldier boy manages to
gain the upper hand yet again and it
looks as though he's about to finish off
starlight huey who has barricaded
himself in the control room has to make
a decision whether or not to take the
temp v to save her but he realizes that
he can boost the power of the stage
lights to make starlight even more
powerful this entire season he's been
under the mentality that he has to be
strong to save her so by casting aside
the temp v he's actually going against
this he doesn't have to save her he has
to be there for her just like his father
who we saw as weak showed strength by
always being there for him by working
together and being there for her
starlight is able to harness her powers
and actually levitate blasting soldier
boy away giving mm the chance to knock
soldier boy out with the gas he says
this is for my family remember that
soldier boy had killed his grandfather
when he was just a boy a story that was
covered up by vaught to make soldier boy
look like a hero soldier boy decides to
blow himself and everyone up he won't
quote go back inside that box referring
to the container he was put in while in
russia but it's maeve here who saves the
day sacrificing herself by tackling him
outside the tower and the two of them
blow up in midair as the dust settles
butcher asks if ryan is okay but the
damage is done both to vaught tower and
their relationship he just wants to
leave with his dad homelander butcher
wipes away more of that black blood and
collapses later waking up in a hospital
where we see him looking at his pendant
of saint christopher this was something
he gave to ryan as a gift at the end of
season two it would later be tossed onto
the ground after butcher was terribly
mean to him the most famous story of
this saint christopher depicts him
carrying a child across a river a child
who would then reveal himself to be
christ is butcher saint christopher and
ryan this christ-like child it hasn't
taken long for vaught to spin the terror
attack at vaught tower as the work of
soldier boy who was radicalized by the
russians although the russians have
denied any such involvement as we can
see here on the news ticker mave
memorials have sprung up but as we'll
soon see ashley is brought security
footage from anika that shows her that
maeve survived will ashley keep this
from homelander and judging by her
saying i'm sorry to maeve at the
beginning of the episode i'm inclined to
think yes let maeve live her life of
secrecy but this also means ashley is
keeping a secret and we know what
homelander does to those who keep
secrets we find out that maeve has lost
her power similar to how kimiko lost
hers while blasted by soldier boy at the
end of episode 4. she's back with her
ex-girlfriend elena who she left in
order to protect her from homelander but
with a new lease on life and homelander
believing her to be dead maeve can
finally get back to her maeve also
recalls the first time that she met
starlight crying after she was assaulted
by the deep we actually saw this scene
in season 1 episode 1. maeve says she'll
go somewhere where homelander can't find
her so it's a big question mark whether
or not the writers decide to continue
her story or have this be her exit out
butcher's use of temp v has finally
caught up to him with the doctor saying
he has about 18 months to live 12 of
those functionally the other six he'll
likely be bedridden mm gives his
daughter something to be proud about
showing her an album of his dad and
grandfather telling her that superheroes
aren't always good janine stops him from
his anxious tapping calling him her hero
the end is a montage of different
characters set to elton john's goodbye
yellowbrick road which is all about a
man turning away from the fame glitz and
glamour towards a more simple life this
is indicative of starlight who throws
away her costume leaving her life of
fame to join the boys she says it was
never the costume that gave her power
that always came from within grace
mallory oversees soldier boy being put
away it's interesting that they haven't
killed him here always leaving the door
open for soulja boy to make a return in
future seasons the deep eats his
feelings watching cassandra on a vaught
morning program promoting her new book
in too deep my journey to freedom a play
off the deep's book deeper and deeper
now i don't think this is the last we've
seen of cassandra on the audible deeper
and deeper podcast the deep talks about
cassandra taking hormones perhaps for
having a baby i mean that many hormones
is never a good thing trust me
cassandra just turned the corner on her
whole
we did see him finish with her so if she
did come back i imagined it would be
with child with the boys now running
under a democracy butcher arrives
sipping from a dawn of the seven cup
wonder if he got that from soldier boy
but it's the news flash that grips
everyone's attention senator lamar
bishop's death was deemed an accident
and victoria newman has been announced
as robert singer's new running mate so
it looks like season 4's villains will
include among others victoria homelander
and ryan on the new sticker we see that
the ritz-carlton hotel threatens to sue
ted cruz over unpaid pornography
pay-per-view charges which may be a nod
to when the senator's official twitter
account retweeted an actual adult video
back in 2017. there's another ticker
headline which states florida governor
ron desantis will ban quote woke
starlight snowflake teachers which may
be a nod to the pushback from florida
teachers and the don't say gay bill at a
pro homeland or rally his home teamers
have toppled this statue of soldier boy
which once stood outside vote square the
reporting here is done by nnc which is
just cnn spelled backwards so you can
see why these guys are pissed off at the
mainstream media part of homelander
supporters are storm chasers followers
of stormfront who are basically
neo-nazis there's one guy who's even
dressed up as the cunan shaman who took
part in the january 6 riot at the
capitol homelander introduces everyone
to his son except everyone isn't too
pleased
hold on computer enhance is that an
a-train energy drink homelander is so
pissed that he zaps this starlighter in
front of everyone and it's todd who's
the first one to clap and cheer which
gets the rest of the crowd going this is
a play on donald trump's comment from
2016 where he said he could shoot
someone in the middle of fifth avenue
and not lose any votes where i could
stand in the middle of fifth avenue and
shoot somebody and i wouldn't lose any
voters okay it's like incredible perhaps
the scariest thing here is ryan's face
at the end which turns into this slight
smile like he's proud of his dad for
what he just did this is something i'm
really looking forward to in season four
how this new father-son dynamic plays
out i almost get invincible vibes where
omniman trains his son so it looks like
the big thread of season 4 will be the
boys having to stop victoria newman
however there are multiple loose threads
the show can pick up on like where is
stan edgar he kinda dipped after being
ousted from vaught but will he make
another appearance who is homelander's
mom i've theorized that it could be
stormfront who went missing in the 70s
she would have been the perfect
candidate to impregnate with soldier
boy's seed to create one of the
strongest soups imaginable what about
little nina she hasn't really faced any
consequences for almost killing frenchie
kimiko and sherry and what's up with
victoria newman's daughter she was
injected with that compound v it would
be quite the scandal if the public found
out she gave her own daughter this not
to mention that she's that head-popping
soup herself what will happen to the
boys who operated under the federal
bureau of superhuman affairs will
victoria newman disband them whatever's
in store for us i'm totally stoked the
boys has been one of my favorite shows
of 2022 and that spin-off show can't
come fast enough but what did you think
of season 3 and what do you think will
happen in season 4. thanks for sticking
with me through all these episodes i
hope you'll consider liking and
subscribing for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
think story yt until next time remember
we'll be in the sweet embrace